ciao a rivers e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo prima di iniziare volevo
farvi vedere al volo cosa mi ha inviato
pringles la prova insieme
vediamo un po no vabbè ma è una porta da
calcio portatile io adoro se volete
anche voi dovete semplicemente seguire
tre step step numero 1 acquistare tre
tubi di pringle aderente all'iniziativa
proprio come questo qui ster numero 2
andare sul sito che vi lascio in
descrizione numero 3 e seguire le
istruzioni e partecipare proprio come me
al primo straining passiamo al nostro
video oggi parliamo di mamme in
particolare di quelle cose che fanno
sempre le mamme
buona visione canotta esagerando in
lontano dico più adesso chiamo l'uomo
nero sono la smetti mai voluto tutto
l'uomo nero
c'è un bambino cattivo che non se ne sa
comportare melo vieni a prendere per
favore va bene ha detto che arriva
subito
guarda che piatti non si lavano da soli
e lo sai vero questa casa non è un hotel
e non siamo te non puoi fare quello che
vuoi
ai fan e mamma mai mangiato hai fame sia
un no che devono cucinare qualcosa
amore sei fame dirmelo gianni giochetto
di mete tra un bobcat e tutte sta
andando ogni aiuto per favore non ne
posso più questa comunità permanesse lo
stima ma me la grazia al minuto quando
ho faticato tanto nella vita per avere
una famiglia
e questo il risultato cosa ti passava
ami farmi un messaggino bastava io non
sto una vostra mappa ricercate come una
ferma lavoro pulito ma nessuno mi vuole
bene
parla cosa tonici subito quell'estate
cos passato tutto il giorno
vieni subito mangiare che si raffredda
ciò ai ghiaccioli minati una televisione
che devo vedere il segreto che sta
iniziando e non me lo voglio perdere
anzi 20 subito la tv all amore
come se di fortuna collaborazione di
parmigiana sei felice
ti porto un cubo il callo ritiro sul
momento anche la massa all esordio
compleanno c'è la fila di taglio colare
ricorda ticket e discreto lo faccio 9 il
tuo bene
carmine mourinho corte non ci siamo
capiti
adesso stai zitta mi rispondi adesso vai
subito subito fare i compiti aiuti pure
non c'è qualche problema per tutti e due
scambiano io conto fino a ca se non fili
subito a mettere in ordine alla camera
dica questo il telefono e non e cibi
licata cioè tu a 1 l'aj valutato tutto
il giorno attaccato al telefonino sempre
con l'estetica lì come se siamo meno
smith i calli è il musical di quella
roba da quella roba lì demonio fin dai
vediamo di fare un po di pulizia che ci
abbiamo troppe robe la casa sommersa
non mi piace a buttare questo giorno mi
piace questo vediamo ai bisognosi ma
sono rivestiti via tutto via via via via
via
guarda che cadi non ti dondolare più su
quella sedia
guarda che te lo dico che sta accadendo
è guardare però abbiamo detto allora
forse non ci siamo capiti che prima o
poi scappa non mi troverete più made in
africa vengono i bisognosi
vogliamo dare cosa fa la presenza di ma
bel po non sa già che abbiamo di purezza
dell'area metterà certo perché le
manette stanno le gambe vero che
spariscono
parlo da che siete la trovo con la
maglietta scommettiamo che trovo
guarda cosa che avevo detto era proprio
il cassetto mi dicevo io mi trovi mai
niente the sun anfratti l'acqua ha
chiesto tutto controllo che piero
veramente non basta far affidamento su
nessuno non ci sono parole proprio un
rinomato che stava male o tu non volevi
parola matrice dammi qualcosa non torna
e faccio due ore la puzza miei calzini
subito subito in azione non ce lo
scandalo mutante che ti vergogni da
camelo sta andando benissimo a scuola
sia adesso sta facendo i compiti
si no ma subito non vede l'ora di
parlarti è da un ora che me lo chiede
trovasto te lo passo subito purtroppo
siamo arrivati alla fine del video
fatemi sapere se vi è piaciuto ma
soprattutto fatemi sapere lasciando un
commentino qui sotto se anche voi almeno
una volta nella vita
avete detto una di queste frasi se non
avete ancora fatto ricordatevi
iscrivervi al mio canale e attivare la
campanella che trovate vicino al tasso
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati su tutti i miei video e
soprattutto essere i primi a commentare
ricordatevi inoltre di seguirmi su tutti
gli altri social facebook music a
sinistra io vi mando un bacione ci
vediamo al prossimo video ciao
[Musica]